[Applaudissements]
j'étais secrètement amoureux de marina
foïs ans je vous jure que m
voilà là là je vous donne un vrai
dossier marina foïs j'étais votre
stagiaire à comédie et je vous qui fait
de ouf
mais je crois vous aviez un mec à
l'époque sûrement avec rien vu ah bah
c'est normal on voit rien j'ai chez moi
jamais non mais vous aviez un mec à
l'époque alors est ce que c'est si on ne
savait pas qui avec qui vous voudriez
faire le show et la web et bah je prends
marina foïs
en fait la question je vous la pose et
aussi à slimane et et marina en fait la
question des simples avant de partir en
pub on disait voilà si voilà il ya
quelqu'un vous le rencontrez vous savez
que personne ne le saura voilà le
lendemain